six months after war erupted in europe
there are growing fears here in asia
that conflict could be coming here too
so i've come to taiwan to work with our
local team here and speak with foreign
minister joseph wu about the surging
tensions with china
is this region on a slippery slope
towards a devastating conflict
and what is taiwan doing to avoid it
josefu thank you so much for joining dw
and taking the time to speak with us
we're speaking just as there's another
sign of the tensions across the taiwan
strait um a chinese drone that was
flying over one of the outlying islands
very close to the chinese mainland
taiwanese troops fired warning shots at
that
what are you trying to say with those
warning shots and how do you interpret
like what are these drone flights which
are so persistent it seems what are they
trying to achieve uh for the uh
the drones flying over jimin
specifically the chinese are trying to
engage in cognitive warfare they want to
shoot some scenes
and to show in their social media
to show that the taiwanese soldiers are
incompetent things like that
and therefore the chinese will continue
to do it
when they find that those kinds of
footages are useful for them for their
domestic propaganda but i think that's
just a small part of what china is
trying to do to taiwan
if you look at what china is trying to
do to taiwan it's a large picture of
their military ambition over us
for example if you look at
the first part of august
they conducted missile tests
and then large-scale
air and sea exercises and also cyber
attacks
uh disinformation campaign
and economic coercion so if you put all
this together together with the drones
disturbances to our outer islands this
is part of their playbook in the future
invasion of taiwan
the minister for the jimmy incident um
your spokesperson called china a thief
and the original troublemaker is it too
harsh this is like war of words
help ease the attention
uh no actually if you look at what
china's spokesperson
in its military ministry of foreign
affairs was saying
he was saying that taiwan is part of the
chinese territory and therefore for the
chinese drone to fly over chinese
territory is nothing
but that is very offensive
because taiwan is not part of china and
we are not chinese territory
and for the chinese foreign ministry
spokesperson to say that
it's unacceptable to the taiwanese
people and therefore we have to fight
back
by saying that that is unwelcomed
minister wu i mean we've seen during the
course of these exercises and since the
exercise is also ostensibly finished
that china has been uh defining a kind
of new normal is the expression uh that
they're uh traversing the the median
line of the taiwan strait uh more
frequently how is taiwan going to be
responding to this new normal
uh this is a tough situation for us i
must be very frank about this
even though the chinese government has
already announced the end of their
large-scale joint military exercises
but their military activities along the
taiwan strait or around taiwan has not
stopped
they continue to fly their airplanes and
sell their ships to the waters or
airspace near taiwan
to
patrol the area
or trying to
upset
the status quo
when we did
when we recorded their air activities uh
they had between five to 15 airplanes
crossing the medium line of the taiwan
strait and two to three times of that
number of sorties conducting air
exercises either
in the northern part or southern part of
taiwan's adiz so the kinds of
disturbances to us or aggression against
taiwan is still there so even though
with the
announcement of the end of large-scale
military exercises they continue to do
it and if you look at their ships coming
close to taiwan they they have between
five to eight military ships coming very
close to taiwan right uh before the 24
mile uh
24 mile uh let me see adjacent water
line so the situation is still very
tense and we have been keeping alert and
this is the situation that we say china
is trying to destroy the status quo or
at least the symbol of the sales quote
which is the median line of the taiwan
strait you know the medium line of
taiwan strait has been there for decades
safeguarding peace and stability over
the taiwan strait and without that
tested agreement the two militaries are
going to come very close to each other
and the chinese are coming so close that
it
compressed the depths of our air defense
and it can create a very dangerous
situation uh status quo across the
taiwan strait has been uh been seen as
the interest of all parties concerned in
this area or
globally and when china is trying to
destroy the status quo is not in the
interest of us
or the international community minister
you talked about the median lie but
china says they have never agreed on
that does that mean this unofficial
demarcation line is not there anymore uh
we wish that or i should say yeah we
hope that it's still there because it's
been there for decades safeguarding
peace and stability across the taiwan
strait uh the chinese uh has this long
plane
in destroying the cisco
uh their military spokesperson last year
uh last june uh say that there's no such
thing as the medium line of the town
straight
uh and this year uh the spokesperson of
the ministry of foreign affairs say that
the whole taiwan strait is china's
waters
it's not international water it belongs
china's sovereignty and china has a
sovereign jurisdiction over the taiwan
strait but taiwan strait in reality has
been international water for a long long
time and therefore the chinese have this
point
to make sure
that its claims
can support
its military activities and this is
exactly what they are trying to do they
say there's no such thing as the medium
line of the town straight and they fly
their airplanes across the medium line
and these kinds of activities are
destabilizing
and it's provocative and can be very
dangerous and we oppose it uh and i
think the international community
especially coming from the federal
democracies they all oppose what china
has been doing
now you've described the the exercises
that have been taking place and you
describe this kind of ratchet effect
of great attention across the strait but
you describe the exercise as a kind of
rehearsal uh for for a potential
invasion
um
what is your sense are you concerned
that an invasion really is potentially
coming and if so what kind of a timeline
are you currently looking at well i
cannot comment on the timeline
but if you look at the chinese statement
the statements coming from their senior
officials
they've been saying that taiwan belongs
to china
and they want to unify with taiwan
peacefully if possible and by force if
necessary and this is not only some
officials it's virtually all officials
are talking about this beginning from xi
jinping himself
and in order to substantiate this kind
of claim
they have been conducting military
exercises along the taiwan strait or
around taiwan for a long time
if you look at the trajectory of their
military threat against taiwan
in the last few years you see more and
more chinese airplanes there are sorties
coming close to our adiz
and they are flying closer and closer to
taiwan
and their ships are also increasing in
number
creating threat scenarios
so if you put all this together you see
that the chinese seems to be preparing
for a war against taiwan for what they
claim unification
of their country so
what they were doing at the first part
of august uh
which is a
exercise according to their playbook
against taiwan uh let me say it again
they fired missiles to the waters near
taiwan
they conducted very large scale air and
sea exercises they conducted cyber
attacks against taiwan they conducted a
disinformation campaign against taiwan
and at the same time they also engage in
economic coercion so put it all together
this is what they want to do to taiwan
when they want to invade taiwan
and all of this these exercises were a
response to nancy pelosi's visit here at
the beginning of august when you reflect
on that visit there was a lot of debate
about whether it was the right thing to
do
was it worth it for all of this
let me make a clarification
the chinese were claiming that speaker
pelosi's visit to taiwan
is something that they need to respond
to
but speaker pelosi's visit to taiwan is
just
one of those
strings of the visitors coming to taiwan
and there was
presidents for example newt gingrich
also visited taiwan before we have so
many senators and congressmen or senior
officials
visiting taiwan from other parts of the
world
and
from this you can see that china just
used this as a pretext to launch that
military threat against taiwan and what
i would say is that speaker pelosi is
special to taiwan it's a moral booster
for the chinese people
taiwan has been facing the threat from
china for all this time
and if there's anyone
want to show their support for taiwan he
or she is highly appreciated
and speaker pelosi is a notable american
leader and her willingness to come to
taiwan to show support to the chinese
people i think this is a great thing for
the taiwanese people
to see and the chinese people throughout
surveys or through real actions they
show their enthusiasm in welcoming the
speaker and after speakers visit to
taiwan even though with the chinese
military threat there are more people
who want to come to taiwan and show
their support and you're seeing some
visitors in taiwan at this time because
they want to show support to taiwan and
all these kinds of shows of support to
taiwan are highly appreciated
and
for the chinese claims i think we need
to clarify
that china just want to find the pretext
if they don't find the pretext of
speaker pelosi's visit to taiwan they
will find something else and they can
always find something else if they can
find speaker pelosi scheduled to taiwan
as an excuse to launch such a large
military scale uh exercises i think they
can find many more extra many more
excuses so that's just the chinese
authoritarian way of doing things
and let me tell you in a very frank way
the chinese military threat against
taiwan will not stop taiwan from making
more friends
and at the same time it will not stop
international friends to come to taiwan
and show their support to us
minister what is your assessment of
russia's invasion of ukraine people have
been calling it a wake up call for
taiwan what lessons are you drawing from
how the world is unfolding
uh this is a very interesting question
uh at the same time we see the war in
ukraine is still going on we also see
the chinese military trade against
taiwan increasing
over in the european theater
we saw that back in 2014
russia
took hold of crimea
and the world response was not enough to
stop russia
from going further
and now we end up a war
in ukraine
and in ukraine we saw that was truly
unfortunate that a democracy
or a southern country that was under
attack by an authoritarian regime
but the ukrainians were showing their
bravery
by defending their country defending
their democracy and the kinds of bravery
also attracted lots of international
support so that is inspirational to the
chinese people because we understand
that the chinese can also do the same
thing to taiwan and by that time we want
to show to the international community
that we are just about
the same degree of bravery in fighting
for our country fighting for our
democracy fighting for our people and
fighting for our democratic way of life
and in east asia if you look at the
longer span of political events
hong kong
is something that we need to keep in
mind as well
just a couple of years ago when the
chinese government was imposing the
national security law on hong kong to
take away every bit of freedom away from
the hong kong people
a lot of people around the world are
asking
is chinese government going to stop at
hong kong or who is the next and at that
time a lot of people are already talking
about taiwan might be the next and i
think the story can go further
is taiwan going to be the last target
of the chinese authoritarian expansion
i would say no
the reason is very clear china also
claims east china sea and they'll be
conducting military exercises or sending
their ships to the disputed water china
also claims south china sea and their
daily patrol of the south china sea
either by their bombers or by their
warships uh is uh so frequent uh these
days is china limited uh what is the
chinese ambition limited to east china
sea taiwan strait and the south china
sea i can tell you no if it's not
stopped
china already signed a security
agreement with the sonoma islands which
is very far away from china
and if we don't stop it
the chinese government is going to sign
more security agreements with more
pacific countries
remember
the chinese leader has already said the
pacific ocean is big enough to
accommodate china and the united states
that's how ambitious they are and are
they limited to the indo-pacific region
or the pacific area i would say no if
you look at the naval bases they are
building in the
cambodia
in myanmar
in pakistan
in sri lanka all the way to djibouti i
think they have global ambition
and the expansion of authoritarianism
always is at the cost of democracy and i
think it's a time for democracy to unite
to stop the authoritarianism from
expanding further mr wu though um i mean
how seriously is taiwan taking this
threat in military terms i mean
we've heard very recently taiwan is
increasing its defense budget by almost
14 from 2022 to 2023 but that still just
takes defense spending to 2.4 percent of
gdp if we compare that with the united
states it spends 3.7 percent israel
which faces maybe a similar sort of
existential threat
5.6
uh how how is it enough for taiwan to be
spending less than half of what israel
spends on its defense this is a very
good question
we understand that
the defense is not free
and it may cost a lot of money and
therefore if you look at the increase of
our monetary budget in the last few
years it's been increasing steadily and
other than increasing our monetary
budget we also conducted the reform of
our military strategy
for example we have already established
an all-out defense mobilization agency
responsible for designing how taiwan can
mobilize itself for the homeland defense
and we also acquire asymmetric weapons
and to discuss with the united states
how we can best approach
the strategy of asymmetric symmetricity
and this is the kind of things that we
are looking at
and we of course understand that the
more military budget is needed and other
than the regular military budget as you
saw from the press
we also have special budget uh that is
used for uh items like missiles or uh
jet planes so these are what we try to
do and we understand the importance of
this and the government is
determined to increase our monetary
budget so do you think the people of
taiwan need to kind of
anticipate maybe spending here needs to
hit the five percent of gdp kind of
range sort of comparable to israel well
if you look at the the increase of
taiwan's economy in the last few years
uh the kinds of increase that we have is
already substantial and what i can tell
you is that the government is determined
to continue to increase our monetary
budget
um at the same time of course taiwan is
very very dependent on the united states
for for its security in terms of
providing weapons and also the sort of
implicit uh
promise of support from the united
states but i want to talk about what
we've heard from president biden over
the last year or so
on three separate occasions joe biden
has
said yes the united states would defend
taiwan going beyond the official u.s
policy only for the white house press
team within 24 hours having to walk that
back and say oh no no nothing's changed
it's exactly the same
how does that how does that make you
feel this sense of complete confusion
about the us policy
um coming from the president himself
well we're not confused
uh we are very clear
that the defense of taiwan is our own
responsibility
and we also are very clear about what
the taiwan relationship says the taiwan
relations act says that the united
states is obligated to provide taiwan
with defensive articles
and the u.s has been living up to the
commitment
of the taiwan relations act and we
appreciate that very much
in the last few years
our relations with the biden
administration has been very well and
going very strong and we have been
discussing taiwan's defense need
the kinds of defense strategies that
taiwan will need to be able to defend
itself so we don't doubt on the u.s
commitment to taiwan it's been very
clear
and i need to tell you once again
the defense of taiwan is our own
responsibility if we are not committed
to our own defense
we don't have the right to ask others to
sacrifice and under these kinds of
circumstances we need to show that we
are determined to defend ourselves and
just like the case of ukraine it's only
the ukrainian people showed their
determination to defend themselves now
you can see the outpouring of
international support for ukraine
and that is what we are looking at too
yes but but i want to return to biden's
comments because you say you're not
confused but i'm confused and many of
people are confused about what why joe
biden
said that said something that we have
promised to go beyond what was really
promised how do you interpret that is he
creating a kind of
next level strategic ambiguity
uh is he having a senior moment is he on
top of things
how what's your interpretation well we
have been working together with the
biden administration as a whole
and we've been speaking to senior
officials and what the u.s policy is and
what the united states support will be
and this kind of a real situation has no
ambiguity to us and we understand that
the us is committed to providing weapons
to taiwan for taiwan self defense and
the u.s is also seriously engaging
taiwan for security discussions so these
are what the united states has been
providing and we
will continue to discuss with the united
states and what we would need and other
than that
you should probably also look at the u.s
presence in this region and the way they
show their presence in this region
just a couple of days ago you saw two
u.s ships setting through the
tama strait
that is the way the united states is
showing its presence in this region and
by doing that i think the u.s is showing
its commitment to peace and stability in
this region and it is not just the
united states that is doing that
we saw australia canada uk france and
etc they also sent their ships to this
region to conduct freedom of navigation
operations in line with their
indo-pacific strategy so it's not only
the united states that has a stake in
peace and stability in this area
it's a lot of countries that understand
the stake of peace and stability in this
area and they want to show that they
care about this by sending their ships
to this region minister there are around
two million taiwanese people living in
china and china is taiwan's largest
trading partner isn't your government
simply too dependent on the us putting
eggs in the same basket
well a lot of people are saying
different things
uh some people are saying that we are
too dependent on china and at the same
time there are also people criticizing
the taiwanese government for depending
solely on
the united states
but the real situation is like this you
know our relations with china is quite
complicated uh
on the same you know on one hand uh
china is our number one trading partner
and probably number one or number two uh
destination for our outbound investment
and that is the fact that we cannot deny
but at the same time china is also our
only source of threat
and that is also the fact that we have
we have to reckon with and when china is
threatening taiwan to such a degree
we have to look around and see who else
can provide taiwan with support and we
see the united states and we see other
democracies so this is what we can count
on if there's going to be more
hostility in between taiwan and china
we need to unite the federal democracies
to come to taiwan's support and i think
the support has been increasing
if you look at the statements of g7 or
nato summit
or
eu summit or other platforms of two plus
twos
you can see that there are more and more
discussions of taiwan issue they all
talk about the importance of peace and
stability over the taiwan straight
indirectly they are saying that chinese
military trade against taiwan is
unwelcomed so this is the situation we
are seeing we not only rely on the
united states we have more and more
support from fellow democracies now the
head of the main opposition party here
the guam dang eric jew we've been
speaking to him
he's been speaking to dw as well
he's accusing your government of i quote
putting taiwan in a dangerous situation
uh by not having sufficient dialogue not
attempting dialogue with mainland with
beijing
he says that the ukraine war shows that
taiwan needs to seek that dialogue what
do you say to that
well
i'm the minister of foreign fs i don't
want to get into a domestic political
debate
but the reality is like this
taiwanese government has been open to
dialogues with china
the president says that the government
officials have been repeating that as
long as china is willing to discuss with
taiwan without any preconditions taiwan
will be very forthcoming in engaging in
dialogue with china and therefore
criticizing taiwan government for not
having the dialogue is barking upon the
wrong trees
i think it's what the chinese government
wants to do they want to
cut off the connections or
communications with the taiwanese
government and create
internal confusions over here or to
create internal contradictions in taiwan
so that taiwan is weakened and we will
not fall into that trap but do you see
any scope
for negotiations achieving anything with
china going anywhere with china i mean
you mentioned before that we have these
kind of two
almost implacable opposites we have xi
jinping and the chinese communist party
saying that they're adamant they want to
as they put it reunify with taiwan
in taiwan we have public opinion only a
vanishingly small percentage of people
want to unify with china
how do we resolve this without war
uh there's a lot we can do
i'm not 100 uh
optimist
but i always try to see uh the kinds of
opportunities are out there and i think
the best opportunity lies in taiwan
itself taiwan is a democracy we are
fully open to all kinds of opinions and
taiwan's democracy is stable and
resilient and as long as taiwan can stay
democratic i think there's always a very
good future for taiwan and as long as
taiwan stays democratic we will continue
to receive support from the
international community and this is not
going to go away taiwan will be a
democracy and when we uh go out of
position uh
you know by this uh term of the
president we are going to pass on to our
next generation these very solid founded
democracy and this democracy is going to
prevail in the long run on the contrary
if you look at china's political system
it might look powerful
and it might look threatening but
authoritarian regimes might profoundly
weak look at their domestic issues
that they have to handle these days um
maybe all of a sudden the chinese people
will say that uh no this is not what we
want we want something like taiwan so
you counting on the the chinese
communist party collapsing and democracy
coming to china is that your greatest
hope
no that's not what i say and i'm not
going to predict
but we have faith in taiwan's democracy
as long as we are democratic i think we
will be doing fine the chinese military
threat is there that is one fact that we
have to reckon with and will continue to
beef up our defense capabilities
so that we can defend ourselves but at
the same time the chinese military
threat is there and if the chinese
military threat against taiwan is
unwelcome not only by the taiwanese
people but also by
the world at large i think the
international community will come
together and tell the chinese leaders
that you are military trade against
taiwan is not a good solution
minister um now we come to the name of
taiwan well we say taiwan all the time
in english but we all know that in
taiwan the constitution that you abide
by is the constitution of republic china
so we when we talk about this confusion
is your government um pursuing the jury
independence is this a long-term dream
uh that's a very good question
the president president tai was elected
based upon the promises to the people
that we would safeguard the status quo
uh we would look at the status quo as
serving the best interest of all parties
concerned and therefore the policy of
this government is to safely safeguard
the status quo the status quo
that the republic of china taiwan and
the people's republic of china have no
jurisdiction over each other the status
quo that taiwan is already a democracy
the status quo that taiwanese people
have a say over taiwan's future so this
is a status quo over taiwan and that's a
policy that we are pursuing yet you are
on the china's list of taiwan
independence die hards
that's what they claim that's what they
want to impose on me i would say that
i'm the one who wants to pursue and
maintain
taiwan's status quo
joseph wu thank you so much for taking
the time to speak to dw today absolutely
welcome thank you